Você sabia que um nível de ferritina que
o seu laboratório chama de normal pode
estar silenciosamente
destruindo seu fígado e acelerando o seu
envelhecimento em tempo real? É isso
mesmo. Você pega o exame e vê lá
ferretina 400, o laboratório diz que o
limite é 500. Seu médico diz: "Tá tudo
ótimo". Mas você continua cansada com
dores articulares ou ganhando peso. A
verdade conveniente é que a ferretina
não é apenas um depósito de ferro, ela é
um alarme de incêndio. Eu recebo
pacientes toda semana na clínica com a
ferretina nas alturas, achando que estão
fortes, quando na verdade o corpo deles
está gritando pro socorro. Eles estão
inflamados, enferrujando por dentro.
Fica comigo. Nos próximos minutos eu vou
te entregar o protocolo exato de
diferenciação que eu uso. Como saber se
a sua ferretina alta é excesso de ferro
ou se é pura inflamação. E o mais
importante, o que você precisa fazer
hoje para não deixar essa ferrugem
destruir sua saúde metabólica? O que eu
vou te contar agora muda o jogo.
Para a gente começar, precisamos alinhar
o básico. Imagine a ferretina como um
grande armazém, um galpão logístico
dentro das suas células. A função
principal dela é guardar ferro. E por
quê? Porque o ferro livre no sangue é
tóxico. Ele gera radicais livres, ele
enferruja os seus tecidos. Então o corpo
que é sábio empacota esse ferro dentro
de uma proteína chamada ferritina.
Agora aqui tá o pulo do gato, onde a
maioria se perde. Existem dois motivos
para um armazém está cheio até o teto.
Primeiro motivo, você comprou mercadoria
demais, você comeu muito ferro ou tem
uma genética que absorve ferro demais. O
armazém está cheio porque tem muito
produto. Motivo dois, o armazém está
cheio porque você fechou as portas e
trancou tudo lá dentro para proteger o
estoque de um ladrão. Na medicina
chamamos isso de reagente de fase aguda.
Quando seu corpo percebe uma ameaça, que
pode ser bactéria, vírus ou até mesmo a
inflamação crônica da obesidade, ele
pensa: "Opa, bactérias e células
cancerígenas precisam de ferro para se
multiplicar. Eu não vou deixar esse
ferro dando sopa. Então o que que o
corpo faz? Ele sequestra todo o ferro
disponível e tranca dentro da ferritina.
Então a ferritina sobe no exame não
porque você tem ferro demais, mas porque
o seu corpo está em modo de defesa. É
uma barricada de guerra. E é aqui que o
bicho pega na interpretação do exame. Se
você olhar o papel do laboratório, vai
ver lá valor de referência para homens
até 400 NOG por mro. às vezes até mais e
para mulheres é até 200 ou 300. Na visão
funcional integrativa, isso é um
absurdo. Estudos recentes mostram que
homens com ferritina acima de 190 já tem
o risco aumentado de problemas
cardiovasculares. Se você está com 400,
o laboratório diz que é normal, mas
biologicamente você está num estado
inflamatório perigoso. O valor ótimo,
aquele onde você tem longividade de
saúde, é bem mais estreito. Para homens
gostamos de ver entre 80 e 120, no
máximo 150. para mulheres também nessa
faixa 80, talvez até 100, dependendo do
contexto. Acima disso, mesmo dentro da
faixa normal do laboratório, você já
pode estar desenvolvendo o que chamamos
de hiperferritinemia
desmetabólica. Nome complicado, né? Mas
simplificando, é ferretina alta causada
pela bagunça no seu metabolismo,
principalmente resistência à insulina e
gordura no fígado. É o fígado gorduroso,
a tal da esteatose, vazando ferritina
pro sangue porque está inflamado. Não é
excesso de ferro na dieta, é o fígado
pedindo arrego. Tá bom, doutor Alan,
minha ferritina deu 500. Como é que eu
sei se é genética ou se é inflamação?
Anote isso agora, meu caro, minha cara,
porque isso vale ouro. Você não olha
apenas a ferretina. Você precisa pedir
pro seu médico ou médica um outro
marcador chamado saturação de
transferrina. A transferrina é o
caminhão que transporta o ferro. A
ferritina é o armazém. Vamos ao cenário.
Cenário A. Se a sua ferritina está alta,
500 ou 600, e a saturação de transferina
também tá alta acima de 45 ou 50%, isso
indica sobrecarga verdadeira de ferro. O
caminhão está cheio, o armazém está
cheio. Provavelmente você tem uma
condição genética chamada hemocromatose.
Nesse caso, o ferro está transbordando,
lesando órgãos. Cenário B de bola. Se a
sua ferritina está alta na faixa de 500,
mas a saturação de transferrina está no
normal para baixa 25 a 30%. Isso sim é
inflamação. O caminhão está vazio, mas o
armazém está trancado. Isso é classe de
quem tem síndrome metabólica, diabetes
tipo 2 ou esteatose hepática. Entendeu a
diferença? O tratamento é oposto para
cada caso. Se você tem o cenário a, que
é o excesso genético,
a solução muitas vezes é flebotomia, que
é doar sangue ou descartar sangue. É
simples, barato e salva a sua vida. Você
tira sangue, o corpo é forçado a usar o
ferro estocado para fazer sangue novo e
a ferretina baixa. Mas se você tem o
cenário B de inflamação, doar sangue
pode até ajudar um pouco, mas não vai
resolver a causa raiz. Você pode tirar
litros de sangue, mas se continuar
comendo açúcar, farinha, bebendo álcool,
a inflamação continua e a ferritina sobe
de novo na semana seguinte. Então, o que
fazer? Vamos pra prática. O que que você
faz se pegou o exame e deu alto?
Primeiro corte o álcool e a frutose
industrializada, o xarope de milho de
alta frutose que tem no suco de
caixinha, tem nos produtos
industrializados. Tire por 30 dias. O
fígado é o principal regulador da
ferritina. Se você agredir o fígado, a
ferritina sobe. Simples assim. Segundo,
cuidado com suplementos. Vejo muita
gente tomando multivitamina com ferro
sem precisar. Se sua ferina está alta,
ferro suplementar é lenha na fogueira.
Ah, mas eu tô cansado. Cansaço com
fergina alta geralmente é tireoide ou
mitocôndria ruim, não falta de ferro. E
um alerta muito específico e poucos
falam, se você tem ferritina muito alta
e saturação alta, cuidado redobrado com
frutos do mar cruz, como ostras, existe
uma bactéria chamada vibriunificus,
que adora ferro. Então, em pessoas
normais, ela não faz nada. Em quem tem
ferro alto, ela pode causar uma infecção
fulminante. Resumindo a ópera, ferretina
alta não se ignora. Ela é um marcador de
que algo está errado. Ou você está
estocando veneno, que é ferro demais, ou
você está pegando fogo por inflamação.
Não aceite o estatuto normal só porque
não atinge um limite passou de 500.
Busque a causa raiz. Saia do vídeo agora
se você gosta de ficar no superficial.
Eu vou te contar uma verdade
conveniente. O YouTube e os conselhos
aqui me limitam. Aqui eu preciso
simplificar, censurar dosagens, omitir
protocolos controversos. Na comunidade
fechada não tem esse filtro. Eu
compartilho os exatos protocolos que eu
uso na minha clínica, casos de reversão
que parecem possíveis, combinações off
que funcionam e fornecedores confiáveis,
além de interpretação avançada de
exames. É basicamente ter acesso ao meu
cérebro médico sem intermediários. Nós
temos lives semanais respondendo
perguntas, PDF com 47 protocolos
exclusivos, grupo no WhatsApp,
fantástico. Se você quer a visão
funcional real, sem simplificação para
as massas, clica aqui em seja membro. E
não é para curiosos, não é para pessoas
comuns, é para quem quer resultados.
Agora, se você quer ir ainda mais fundo,
existe o nível dois. A cada duas
semanas, fazemos lives de imersão total
com 2 horas de duração, desse artigos
científicos linha por linha e debatendo
controvérsia que ninguém ousa tocar,
revelando os bastidores das pesquisas
que a indústria não quer que você
entenda. E tem mais, seu nome será
mencionado nos vídeos como
agradecimento. Você se torna a parte
visível dessa comunidade elite que está
reescrevendo as regras da medicina.
Enquanto a maioria dorme e assiste
passivamente, você estará ao meu lado
construindo um conhecimento de verdade,
tendo o seu reconhecimento público como
alguém que investe no que realmente
importa. Não é só sobre aprender, é
sobre pertencer ao círculo interno de
quem está mudando o jogo. Poucos têm
essa coragem. Você tem? Agradecimentos
aos nossos queridos membros no grupos
avançados de estudos. Cláudia Leitão,
Alex Caldas, Ana Paula Vascular, José
Fortunato Mutinho, FS Machado RJ, Sou
Jucioli, Cristina Carol, Romana Moraril,
Estela Mares, Elô Terapias Integrativas,
Saúde Lães da Doença. Muito obrigado
pelo seu carinho e pelo seu apoio.